[Musique]
merci ellisabeth doanau de nous
accompagné pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la Mayenne
membre du groupe Union centrrice
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales on va longuement
parler du budget de la Sécurité sociale
que vous avez examiné jusque tard dans
la nuit merci d'être avec nous ce matin
mais d'abord on va commencer par la loi
immigration puisque les sénateurs ont
adopté hier le projet de loi immigration
dans une version durcie par la majorité
sénatoriale de droite et du centre c'est
une victoire comme le dit Bruno
retaillot pour vous écoutez pour moi ça
a été comment dirais-je le fruit de de
négociation parmi les groupes de de la
majorité mais ça a été compliqué parce
que moi je travaillais beaucoup sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale donc je n'ai pas pu
assister au débat moi en fait deux
choses m'ont particulièrement ennuyé
c'est la décision d'interrompre l'ame
bien sûr pour mettre l'AMU mais euh
voilà j'ai pas trop compris en fait
comment les choses se sont organisées de
ce côté-là et moi je je pense qu'en
terme de santé publique il faut manier
tout ça avec beaucoup de précautions et
j'ai été aussi ennuyé par le fait de de
pousser à 5 ans le fait d'être dans le
pays pour bénéficier de certaines
allocations en tout cas moi je suis
depuis toujours sur les politique d'aide
au aux personnes les plus vulnérables et
je me dis que cette affaire est
ennuyeuse parce que si on n pas une
personne qui est en en
situation de demande de titre de séjour
et bien ce sont forcément d'autres qui
pont parce que il y a effectivement
l'État qui peut apporter laad qui est
une aide justement pour demandeur
d'asile mais il y a aussi les
départements qui sont en ligne directe
comme d'ailleurs les les les comment les
communes qui peuvent aussi apporter des
aides donc de toute façon on pourra pas
laisser tout le monde dans la rue hein
je pense que ce sera impossible il y a
déjà assez de familles qui aujourd'hui
sont dans la rue et je pense que les
Français c'est pas ce qu'ils attendent
non plus et c'est des charges qui
retourneront vers les collectivités et
je pense pas que ce soit mieux en fait
juste sur la me c'est un gros point de
crispation entre le gouvernement et et
le Sénat ça veut dire que vous vous
souhaitez que le gouvernement et que les
députés rétablissent l'aide médicale
d'État tel qu'elle existe effectivement
moi je je je le veux parce que en
réalité la la la grosse différence c'est
le droit d'entrée mais quand on est un
demandeur d'asile quand on voilà quand
on vient
d'arriver je ne pense pas qu'on ait la
capacité sinon avec des aides d'obtenir
ces ces moyensl il y a un sujet en
revanche qui a pas été abordé qui est
pas dans le texte même s'il a été abordé
en séance c'est la question des mineurs
non accompagnés c'est un sujet sur
lequel vous travaillez est-ce que vous
regrettez qu'il ait pas eu de de point
dans le texte sur ce sujet alors moi je
l'ai toujours dit parce que j'avais
produit un rapport avec avec un ancien
collègue et et et nous avions été amenés
à la conclusion suivante c'est un
problème d'immigration et pour moi ce
n'est pas l'affaire des départements
parce que quand les jeunes arrivent il
faut les héberger il faut comment les
accompagner et ça coûte très très cher
et il y a surtout l'évaluation et c'est
vrai qu'au départ nous n'avions pas
forcément les professionnels adaptés
pour bien comprendre l'environnement de
de ces jeunes l'évaluation je sais
vérifié qu'ils sont bien mineurs et
temps d'évaluation c'est à la charge des
départements qui sont bien seuls parce
que la mission des départements c'est
effectivement de prendre des jeunes
isolés donc il faut faire un certain
nombre de vérifications et donc il faut
dire que actuellement tout ceux qui Arve
c'estes mineurs et en fait ils ne sont
pas mineursin donc ces évaluations
permettent justement d'évaluer la
situation et de dire s'ils sont de la
responsabilité des départements ou pas
et aujourd'hui on estime que c'est à peu
près 2/3 de ces jeunes en fait mais le
temps que on fasse l'évaluation ils sont
hébergés par les départements et donc
c'est une très très lourde charge j'ai
toujours dit ça devrait être au niveau
de l'état de prendre ces jeunes en
charge autre sujet d'actualité ce sont
ces actes antisémites 1518 c'est le
nouveau chiff donné par Gérald armanin
depuis le 7 octobre il y a une tribune
qui a été euh signée pardon par plus de
90 sénateur dont vous pour appeler un
surceaut national contre l'antisémitisme
il a pas eu lieu pour vous ce sursaut au
dimanche ah si il a eu lieu alors c'est
vrai que en en province nous étions
réunis devant les préfectures il y avait
certes sans doute beaucoup moins de
monde que à Paris mais de de voir ce
cortège à Paris qui était dans une
certaine sérénnité on sentait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de solennité en fait et
bien ça ça m'a rassuré en quelque sorte
mais je pense qu'il faut continuer il
faut rester précisément très comment en
vigilance par ce dimanche ce ne soit
qu'une parenthèse ben
écoutez je je ne sais pas moi je ne sais
pas ce que les Français feront voilà en
majorité mais moi je reste vigilante
parce que ce qui est fait au peuple juif
et bien en fait est une atteinte aussi à
la liberté de de chacun de toute
confession et et je pense que le racisme
la discrimination quelelle qu'elle soit
est à combattre ouais d'autant que
Gérald harmanin vous l'a dit la semaine
dernière c'était devant le sénateur sur
le profil des des gens qui commettent
ces actes antisémites qui sont souvent
très jeunes est-ce que c'est ça aussi
qui doit inquiéter je pense que c'est
c'est inquiétant notre société est
vraiment dans une situation particulière
je je pense que partout on voit cette
violence se se multiplier et de plus en
plus jeune mais je dirais que ça se
passe aussi bien dans le milieu urbain
que en milieu rural on voit aussi des
expressions très violentes en fait de
discrimination et et et ça ça ça me
choque mais ça m'inquiète beaucoup donc
restons très vigilant on va parler du
budget de la Sécurité sociale puisque
vous l'examinez depuis lundi après-midi
au Sénat on va faire le point sur ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières heures avec
Steve
[Musique]
Jourdin bonjour bonjour bonjour madame
la sénatrice et siive le Sénat poursite
donc l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale oui
le budget de la SQ les élus fixent
actuellement les dépenses et les
recettes pour l'année prochaine l'examen
a débuté euh a débuté au Sénat lundi
c'est un gros morceau hein près de 1400
amendements une cinquantaine d'articles
cette affaire va nous tenir en haleine
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine on passera
ensuite à la loi de financeces pour
l'année prochaine alors hier dans
l'hémicycle il était notamment question
de notre système de retraite il y a
quelques semaines le gouvernement avait
émis l'idée de ponctionner une parti des
caisses du régime complémentaire de
retraite agic Arco pour renflouer euh
les caisses du du régime général qui est
déficitaire mais les partenaires sociaux
n'en veulent pas et sous la pression et
bien le gouvernement avait finalement
annoncé qu'il renoncerait à une telle
mesure hier les sénateurs ont voulu s'en
assurer écoutez dans un souci de clarté
politique et juridique cet amendement
vise à supprimer les dispositions
prévoyant une contribution de l'IR Carco
au titre de la solidarité financière du
système de retraite qui alimente
aujourd'hui les craintes des partenaires
sociaux et de vous-même chers collègues
sans Pr voir pour autant de solutions en
cas de blocage des négociations les
sénateurs ont supprimé une mesure dans
le texte une mesure qui aurait permis à
l'exécutif de ponctionner les caisses du
régime complémentaire en cas d'échec des
négociations des négociations qui ont
lieu actuellement entre partenaires
sociaux pour déterminer une éventuelle
contribution au régime général et si le
Sénat a aussi dit non à la diminution
des ressources de l'assurance chômage
oui le gouvernement voulait pouvoir
récupérer des excédents réalisés par
l'Unedic l'association qui gère la
assurance chômage excédent rendu
possible par la réforme de l'assurance
chômage précisément engagé par
l'exécutif et à l'allègement des
contributions patronal l'État aurait pu
récupérer jusqu'à 2,5 milliards d'euros
selon les estimations pour les
réinvestir ditil ensuite dans la
politique de l'emploi mais les sénateurs
s'y sont là aussi opposés écoutez
ponction qui va obliger l'Unedic à
souscrire de nouveaux emprunts plus
chers pour honorer ses remboursements
pour un coût supplémentaire de 800
millions à l'horizon 2026 donc je voilà
je vous demande donc de de soutenir cet
amendement pour éviter ce véritable
holdup sur les ressources de l'Unedic
madame la sénatrice il é question de ces
deux réformes de ces deux grandes
réformes du gouvernement réforme de
l'assurance chemage réforme des
retraites deux réformes qui ont permis
de dégager des excédents pourquoi vous
avez refusé au gouvernement d'en
profiter pour rééquilibrer certains
comptes j'ai envie de dire au
gouvernement bien essayer en réalité ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le budget de
la Sécurité sociale tel qu'il est
présenté cette année est déficitaire
beaucoup moins déficitaire que les tro
années précédentes puisque nous n'avons
plus les charges qui incombaient
finalement la sécurité sociale pour
répondre à la crise sanitaire donc là on
est à 8,8 milliards d'euros de déficit
mais en fait dans la projection dans la
trajectoire budgétaire on voit que le
déficit va s'accentuer d'année en année
pour arriver à 17,5 milliards d'euros
en 2027 donc en réalité il y a un aveu
d'impuissance de réduire le déficit et
c'est pour ça que l'État le gouvernement
a eu l'idée d'aller voir où il y avait
de l'argent et il y a de l'argent au
niveau des administrations de sécurité
sociale notamment à l'Unedic et
également à l'agir Carco moi je pense
que d'une part l'Unedic a une dette elle
aussi on n' pas vécu une situation comme
celle-ci à l'Unedic depuis quelques
années il y a effectivement ement le
fait que le chômage aujourd'hui est
réduit que nous avons davantage
d'emplois donc davantage de cotisation
il y a eu deux réforme aussi de l'Unedic
qui permettent aussi d'améliorer les
finances de l'Unedic et il y a cette
réforme des retraites qui permet d'avoir
plus de
cotisant si la situation de l'Unedic est
meilleure je pense qu'il faut en
profiter pour régler les anciens
déficits on a quand même à peu près 56
57 milliards d'euros de déficit à
l'Unedic et l'Unedic a présenté un plan
a purement de sa dette et je trouve que
c'est vertueux que de dire aujourd'hui
et bien voilà vous vous lancez dans dans
cette opération de désendettement c'est
vertueux et c'est ce que nous disons
nous aussi pour le budget la sécurité
sociale il faudrait commencer à avoir
une trajectoire qui va vers l'équilibre
comme c'était prévu en 2019 mais sur le
sur le régime d'airetraite alors Thomas
CASNAV il s'est opposé à l'amendement il
dit il s'agit pas d'une ponction mais de
tirer les conséquences de la fermeture
des rég des régimes spéciaux il a tort
bah je pense qu'il donne des raisons lui
aussi hein qui abonde dans dans dans le
sens qui qu'il veut moi je pense que
nous nous faisons vraiment confiance au
paritarisme et le débat avec l'ensemble
des syndicats est important c'est c'est
l'argent finalement des des salariés et
donc c'est à eux de débattre et de
discuter de ce qu'ils vont faire il y a
eu à certains moment des moyens qui
étaient pas aussi je dirais florissant
hein pour l'agire Carco ils ont fait des
efforts et donc donc aujourd'hui ils
peuvent se permettre justement de
rattraper un petit peu ses efforts donc
laissons-les organiser finalement leur
excédent pour les années qui viennent
c'est à voir d'ailleurs si ça continue
très longtemps parce que rien ne nous
annonce que voilà il n'y ait plus de
crise on a vécu la crise sanitaire on
vit la crise voilà économique de
l'énergie et cetera c'est c'est c'est
quand même tellement imprévisible à
venir que justement pendant les périodes
fastes on doit en tout cas soit régler
sa dette ou en tout cas engranger un peu
d'avance pour justement euh venir euh
plus facilement en période de crise mais
est-ce que ça veut dire cette volonté de
ponctionner laag Carco que la réforme
des retraites n'a pas du tout réglé la
question du déficit du régime général de
retraite ah mais certainement et
d'ailleurs c'était prévu hein lorsque
nous avons débattu c'est ce que
contestaiit beaucoup de ceux qui étaient
contre cette réforme des retraites le
gouvernement avait même annoncé que
c'était 6,5 milliards d'euros en moins
sur le déficit mais il restait un
déficit et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est
prévu pour 2027 c'est un déficit de 14
milliards d'euros donc ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir passer par une nouvelle
réforme des
retraites en tout cas on n'a pas réglé
le problème le problème c'est que il
faut des cotisants pour régler les
pensions et si on a plus de pensionnés
il faut donc plus soit ponctionner ou
alors baisser les pensions je veux dire
qu'on est au pied du mur c'est c'est ce
que nous avons toujours dit depuis 4 ans
au Sénat la réforme est arrivée elle a
été contestée mais il n'empêche que le
problème est là
Steve oui vous avez d'autres questions
sur l'assurance notamment sur sur
l'assurance chômage puisqu'on en parlait
tout à l'heure compte excédentaire de
4,4 milliards d'euros en 2023 prinéic
vous dites quand même merci à Emmanuel
Macron d'avoir engagé toutes ces
réformes écoutez je pense qu'elles
étaient nécessaires et que c'est
heureusement sérieux qu'on ait pu
engager effectivement cette réforme des
retraites qui ne règle pas tout mais qui
permet d'être en tout cas beaucoup moins
déficitaire qu' je parle l'assurance
chageurance chaage oui oui oui tout à
fait tout à fait je pense que de toute
façon la plupart des Français
souhaitaent que les choses se durciss à
ce niveau-là parce qu'il fallait que les
revenus du travail et bien soi plus
avantageux que que les revenus de
substitution et en l'occurrence on est
très on était très généreux en France et
donc il fallait revoir un peu les choses
parce que c'est une question de de
ressenti de justice sociale et donc je
pense que oui oui ces réformes était
nécessairire vous comptez sur le sur le
gouvernement pour maintenir IR toutes
ces modifications lorsque le texte
repassera à l'Assemblée nationale
écoutez oui en tout cas nous on montre
un chemin après on est pas forcément
suivi par les députés et nous verrons en
commission mixte paritaire si on peut
s'entendre mais c'est un petit oui quand
même parce que là le gouvernement a
déclenché le 493 ça veut dire que
maintenant il a la main sur le texte et
que s'il veut il peut ne tenir aucun
compte de tout ce que vous allez voter
comme modification est-ce que vous
pouvez vraiment peser sur ce budget et
est-ce qu'il y a des mesures où vous
dites là c'est indispensable de les
garder ah écoutez c'est tout tout tout
est àaire de négociation en quelque
sorte il y a le contexte du PLFSS mais
il y a aussi le contexte je dirais
national et je crois que la majorité a
besoin d'alliés donc il faut peut-être
aussi nous faire quelques preuves
quelques actes d'amour si vous voulez je
pense
que ça veut dire que pour pour vous vous
envoyez un message politique mais vous
attendez aussi du gouvernement qui fasse
un peu de politiqueû bienû sûr et il
faut sortir du contexte de la sécurité
sociale je dirais que c'est un ensemble
et ce qu'on peut négocier pour la
sécurité sociale c'est aussi peut-être
par rapport à d'autres projets de loi je
pense que le gouvernement à l'heure
actuelle a besoin d'allier alors ils
sont plus ou moins voilà identifiés à
chaque projet de loi ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes vous pensez à quel
projet de loi en particulier bah sur
l'immigration par exemple mais voilà je
pense que il faut s'écouter moi je pense
ça veut dire vous serez moins clin en
compromis parce qu'il va il va devoir
falloir trouver un compromis vous serez
moinsclin vous les centristes au
compromis si le gouvernement ne tient
aucun compte de vos modifications sur le
budget de la
SCU je pense qu'il faut que chacun se
sente en tout cas respecté euh dans son
analyse et dans ses propositions il y a
il y a un point sur le gouvernement n'a
sur lequel le gouvernement n'a pas
tranché et qui qui concerne les Français
c'est la question de l'augmentation des
franchises ce qui reste à à la charge du
patient quand il va chez le médecin
quand il achète un médicament le
gouvernement avait un temps envisagé de
les augmenter là c'est un peu flou il y
a pas vraiment de réponse que doit faire
le gouvernement selon vous alors on sent
que c était un peu un ballon d'essaiis
hein pour le gouvernement donc ce que ce
que l'on dit nous à la commission c'est
qu'il faut en débattre c'est vrai que
c'est c'est aujourd'hui possible pour le
gouvernement de décider seul mais nous
nous disons que les deux commission des
affaires sociales celle du Sénat et
celle de l'Assemblée nationale ont leur
mot à dire nous sommes la représentation
des Français et donc nous voulons qu'en
tout cas cet échange ait lieu au sein de
nos deux assemblées moi je pense très
sincèrement que il faut que les Français
soient
responsabilisés il faut dire que les
franchises elles sont vraiment très très
basses en tout cas notre système de
santé permet d'être soigné et d'être
très bien remboursé on par d'une
augmentation de 50 centimes et d'un €
oui voilà donc je je sais que pour
certaines personnes c'est important
c'est c'est extrêmement important et
puis qu'il faut faire attention aussi à
ceux qui sont dans des situations de
maladie chronique mais il ne serait pas
concernés en
l'occurrence mais je pense que les
Français doivent se responsabiliser par
rapport à l'usage qu'ils font de la
santé on a parfois des personnes qui se
comportent vraiment comme des
consommateurs au détriment d'ailleurs
des soins qui sont apportés à d'autres
qui ont du mal à avoir accès aux soins
vous avez dit dans dans votre discours
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement finance
la santé par le déficit est-ce que ça
veut dire que les Français doivent aussi
participer à la résorption de ce déficit
je dis il faut responsabiliter
responsabiliser tout le monde il y a
finalement une réponse de sobriété et de
responsabilisation c'est c'est c'est un
déficit important et en fait il y a une
sorte d'aveu d'impuissance de l'État
parce que finalement on a jamais dépensé
autant d'argent quand on voit l'objectif
national des dépenses qui est comment
dirais-je proposé à l'Assemblée et bien
ça n'a jamais été aussi haut et pourtant
les Français n'ont jamais été aussi
insatisfait donc je pense que le message
en tout cas qui doit euh s'infiltrer un
petit peu partout dans la population
c'est l'histoire de se responsabiliser
au niveau du citoyen au niveau des
professionnels de santé au niveau
finalement de l'État parce que l'État
aussi sans doute sur le plan de la
stratégie et et des réformes
structurelles qu'il faut avancer il faut
avoir du courage et donc je pense que du
coup c'est ce que nous demandons nous en
particulier c'est de
diminuer ce déficit parce qu'on ne peut
pas se résoudre à laisser payer nos
consultations par les générations
futures quand vous voyez certains
médecins qui se
déconventionnent c'est-à-dire que leur
les patients ne sont plus remboursés par
la Sécurité Sociale est-ce que ça c'est
un manque de responsabilité de la part
de ces médecins oui je pense que
effectivement on peut on peut
s'interroger mais je comprends aussi
leur réaction moi j'avais posé la
question à Monsieur fatô le le le
directeur de l'ursf parce que j'avais
déjà déj depuis très longtemps observer
cette tendance mais que nous disent les
médecins qui choisissent ce mode
d'exercice c'est que soit ils ne s'y
retrouvent pas dans dans le sens qu'ils
ont donné à leur métier ou soit parce
que il y a les négociations
conventionnelles qui ont été
particulièrement difficile et ils n'ont
pas été entendus sur le de la
consultation par exemple mais mais mais
je je je pense que il y a une réaction
qu'il faut essayer de de comprendre et
il faut essayer de travailler là-dessus
en tout cas les négociations sont sont
reparties moi je pense que les Français
le disent d'ailleurs une consultation
c'est c'est c'est c'est peu coûteux et
quand on sait ce qui reste en plus à la
charge finalement de l'assurée c'est
c'est encore beaucoup plus euh comment
dirais-je euh c'est en tout cas ce n'est
pas important donc en terme de de de
comment de montant je je crois que
effectivement il faut qu'on en rediscute
mais il faut se respecter et et dans la
négociation conventionnelle il faut
effectivement entendre les médecins
merci St merci à tout à l'heure on
parlera de la loi immigration qui a été
votée hier par le Sénat on verra tout ça
avec vous on va continuer à parler des
questions de santé ellisabeth doanau
c'est l'actualité dans nos régions on va
à tour on retrouve Valérie Pernet
bonjour Valérie merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directrice départemental
adjoint de la rédaction de La Nouvelle
République en indr etlois Valérie on
reste avec vous je le disais sur ces
questions de santé on va parler d'un
mouvement de greffe qui touche l'hôpital
pour enfants de tour
oui l'hôpital Clocheville à tour c'est
un hôpital pédiatrique qui dépend du
Centre hospitalier régional
universitaire d'indréloire à l'hôpital
Clocheville la grève a commencer le 2
octobre elle se continue aujourd'hui et
un appel à manifester et même lancé pour
demain dans le cadre de la journée
nationale de mobilisation pour la santé
euh les agents du service de réanimation
de de cet hôpital pédiatrique sont même
en grève eux depuis se sont mis en grève
pour la toute première fois cette été
c'est pour dire si si c'est un mouvement
qui dure euh les infirmiers et aid
soignants notamment ne c cess de tirer
la sonnette d'alarme depuis ces semaines
en raison d'un fort taux d'absentéisme
et d'une fatigue qui s'accumule ils
disent avoir peur de faire des erreurs
ils ont partagé leurs inquiétudes et
leurs conditions de travail dégradé avec
notre journaliste Cécile lassève il lui
expliquait comme on n'est pas assez
nombreux on ne peut pas surveiller tous
les enfants quand l'un d'entre eux se
met à pleurer ça devient compliqué alors
on imagine que la situation est
particulièrement compliquée en ce moment
alors que le que démarre l'épidémie de
bronchiolite qui touche justement les
enfants les plus jeunes actuellement une
dizaine d'enfants de moins de 2 ans sont
hospitalisés dans cet hôpital
Clocheville à tour chaque jour h lits
sont dédiés à cette pathologie tous sont
occupés déjà alors que l'épidémie
démarre tout juste trois enfants sont
même accueillis en réanimation et comme
le l'explique un médecin infectiologue
du CHRU aujourd'hui dans la Nouvelle
République ces chiffres ne vont cesser
d'augmenter dans les dans les semaines à
venir euh l'arrivée d'un nouveau
traitement préventif contre ce virus
respiratoire de la brocolite offre de
l'espoir aux soignants et aux famille
mais pour l'instant les doses
disponibles ne sont pas suffisantes la
distribution est limitée et priorisée
donc à terme peut-être que les hôpitaux
seront un peu moins engorgés mais pour
l'instant les soignants sont très
mobilisés sur cette pathologie et ils le
seront sans doute jusqu'au printemps
donc j'ai une question pour Madame la
Catrice parce que c'est vrai que avec
ces vagues épidémiques on a vraiment
enfin c'est accentué disons pendant ces
vagues épidémiques et pendant cette
période de broncholite particulièrement
mais on a vraiment l'impression que nos
hôpitaux vont craquer même si la
direction du CHRU a annoncé la création
de postes supplémentaires qui qui seront
financés par le Ségure je me demande si
l'État mais suffisamment de moyens pour
la santé publique et la santé des
soignants Elisabeth Donau oui alors moi
je je suis effectivement très attentive
à ce que vous vous annoncez là pour pour
le l'hôpital de tour mais en réalité on
rencontre ces difficultés un petit peu
partout dans le pays et d'ailleurs le
Sénat avait produit un rapport pour dire
enfin pour tirer la sonnette d'alarme en
quelque sorte et depuis on n' pas eu le
sentiment qu'il a été fait grand-chose
moi je rêve du vauan au gouvernement qui
construirait qui qui en tout cas ferait
beaucoup pour pour l'hôpital en tout cas
je l'ai pas encore rencontré mais je
pense que c'est une nécessité que de
revoir toute la stratégie
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
d'exploitation des des hôpitaux parce
que là c'est un 1e hôpital en fait qui
est en grève et quand on sait que ça
concerne des enfants c'est
particulièrement préoccupant et vous
avez raison en tout cas de de le dire
moi je pense que il faut regarder on a
fait de multiples rapports comme je vous
le disais au Sénat mais il y a aussi le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
dernièrement dit mais la situation est
catastrophique et il y a pourtant eu
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
pendant la crise sanitaire vis-à-vis des
hôpitaux et d'ailleurs il se portaiit
presque mieux pendant la crise sanitaire
parce que il y a les garanties de
fonctionnement qui qui ont été mis en
place il y a eu le séure aussi et et et
des possibilités d'investissement mais
on sent bien qu'il n'y a pas de
stratégie mais vraiment sur le
structurel hein et donc là on voit bien
que c'est symptomatique actuellement
l'hôpital est en situation de maladie
chronique hein et donc il faut
absolument agir et moi je le dis he la
balle est dans le camp du gouvernement
il faut absolument c'est une priorité
l'hôpital la santé c'est une priorité et
on n jamais dépenser autant mais je
pense qu'il faut regarder la performance
des dépenses comment on regarde
l'efficience parce que c'est c'est c'est
pas possible de se dire que on va
toujours augmenter les dépenses mais on
est devant des insatisfactions des
situations qui ne sont pas tolérable et
donc moi j'invite le gouvernement à agir
sur ce plan-là et on a bien entendu le
message merci Valérie Pernet merci
beaucoup vous parliez de la broncholly
c'est à la Une de La Nouvelle République
broncholy l'épidémie repart c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Valéri Pernet d'avoir été avec nous
merci ellisabeth douanau merci d'être
venu malgré cette séance tardive et et
l'examen du budget se poursuit
évidemment cet après-midi merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité